des ordres c'est un chouette mot pour
résumer ma vie
[Musique]
les ordres c'est une autofiction c'est à
dire que je joue mon propre rôle on me
suit en fait dans mon quotidien parisien
c'est un peu les coulisses de ma vie
mais évidemment fictionné on n'est pas
dans un reportage on n'est pas dans un
docu donc voilà il y a de la comédie et
puis pas que parce que j'essaie d'avoir
des thèmes qui ne sont plus personnels
comme l'anxiété et puis aussi l'amour
bien sûr il se trouve que le trouble
panique ou le trouble anxieux dont je
souffre et dont je souffre à peu près la
moitié de la planète
occidentale enfin en tout cas du monde
occidental ça se dit désordre si ça peut
se dire disorder exactitude disorder et
je trouve que c'est des ordres c'est un
chouette mot pour résumer ma vie
commençons par 10 mg ça vous va 10 mg
ça sert à rien 20 comme d'hab c'est
câbles à la limite et puis je
je montrais comme ça de 10 à 20 mais
toute cette chimie dans mon corps tout
formé contre
mettez-moi du xanax aussi en cas de
grosse crise quand même j'ai toujours eu
envie de faire une série parce que c'est
un format que j'adore qui se prête très
très bien la comédie et mon univers est
plus proche de l'univers de la série que
de l'univers du cinéma j'aime installer
des personnages qu'on a plaisir à
retrouver et faire la part belle oui
voilà au rôle secondaire et la série ça
se prête vraiment à ça je trouve une
oeuvre audiovisuelle ça permet quand
même d'explorer des émotions différentes
de la scène en tout cas du one man show
parce qu'au théâtre on peut être
vraiment tout aussi ému je pense que au
cinéma mais voilà le média audiovisuel
il permet d'aller vers des émotions un
peu plus subtiles que que la scène et
puis il m'a permis de moi d'aborder des
thèmes qui sont pas très amusants à
aborder sur scène finalement
alors je mets en scène une partie de ma
vie mais évidemment très fictionnée
aucune préparation évidemment puisque
l'intérêt c'était d'être plus proche de
de mon vrai personnage donc fallait
juste pas que je sois trop caricaturale
l'idée c'était d'aller chercher quelque
chose qui pouvait être qui peuvent être
trouver un écho dans le public c'est
d'ailleurs ce que exactement le même
travail que je fais pour la scène ça me
rend hyper heureuse quand je vois que
une de mes observations est partagée je
me dis bon bah on est plusieurs dans le
cadre donc peut-être que ça mérite
d'être abordé il y a une scène où je
présente une cérémonie quand le cancer
du sein etc évidemment je ferai pas ça
dans la vraie vie parce que j'irai pas
jusqu'au naufrage absolu où j'irai pas
jusqu'à mettre dans l'embarras les gens
pour qu'ils se travaillent mais la
comédie parfois exige qui est un petit
dérapage supplémentaire donc je dirais
que c'est moi un peu plus négligeante
voilà un peu plus un peu moins un peu
moins scolaire elle est un peu elle sort
un tout petit peu des clous alors que
moi je suis quand même assez sage on va
dire non il y a beaucoup de choses qui
sont vraies mais je dirais que c'est
plus des choses subtiles je sais qu'il y
a plein de détails pour lesquels je me
suis dit si par exemple c'est mes vrais
fringues c'est mon ça a été un de mes
apparts on l'a retrouvé là partout où
j'ai écrit cette série finalement donc
il y a des détails qui sont vraies qui
vous paraîtront pas important mais qui
moi me donner une légitimité à raconter
mon histoire en ce qui concerne les
anecdotes elles sont un tout petit peu
plus fantasmés que ce qu'elles ont été
dans la vraie vie parce que la fiction
sera ça sinon on s'emmerde
vous inquiétez pas je vous embêterai pas
j'imagine que ça doit être un calvaire
d'être tout le temps sollicité
mais bon on va juste faire une petite
photo
comme ce que j'ai voulu montrer dans la
série c'est à dire qu'il est il fait
partie de ma vie parfois ça empête un
peu plus des situations de malaise voilà
dans la série j'ai un coup de fil d'une
amie à qui il arrive un gros problème de
santé et ben voilà c'est parfois dans
ces moments-là ou tu essayes d'être
voilà disponible et tu peux pas l'être
et on peut pas faire ça c'est comme ça
[Musique]
s'il y avait une chose dont j'avais
envie de parler avec cette série c'est
de ça du trouble anxieux parce que c'est
quelque chose avec lequel je vis depuis
toute petite je rencontre tellement de
gens qui souffrent de ça et qui encore
aujourd'hui ne savent pas ou comment le
traiter ou comment parler ou comment on
l'assumer et que ça empêche certaines
personnes de vivre de sortir de chez eux
donc j'avais envie que ça puisse
réconforter des gens qui souffrent du
même du même trouble de l'anxiété